it's a great to welcome to the program
today brian karam who's an award-winning
journalist and author of the new book
free the press the death of american
journalism and how to revive it great
great having you on brian i appreciate
it thanks a pleasure being here so okay
i mean what when did the death of
american journalism start uh where is
was there a particular period where we
can start to see this demise
sure i blame uh richard nixon and roger
ailes both imps of the devil who
one came into office and you know
committed as many crimes as he could
and the other attached to him and
eventually spawned
mitch mcconnell and fox news
so uh those two together
began our journey and then it was um
ronald reagan who actually implemented
the first seeds that planted the first
seeds of destruction and every
every president in the last 40 years has
had their uh hand in doing it some more
than others some less and when we say
the death of journalism i mean in a
literal sense we have media outlets we
have people called reporters and all of
these things so like what what are you
talking about what is it that has had
that has degenerated
uh well the term for one uh you know to
be a reporter you have to at least have
a at least one copy editor otherwise
you're just some idiot spouting your
opinion and it's okay
i'm all fond of you know
opinions but to be a journalist you have
to vet facts and the process of how we
do that is broken down over the years
how we do it the institution is falling
apart look there's vast media the
biggest problem the the underlying
largest problem in the united states
with journalism is a lack of community
journalism there are vast informational
deserts news deserts in this country
thousands of communities where there is
no local news
and until we fix that problem we can't
fix the bigger problem the smaller
problem has to be fixed with
investing in
community newspapers giving tax breaks
to small business owners you know what's
wrong with a hundred dollar rebate on
your taxes if you so if you can prove
you subscribe to a newspaper or a radio
station or something that's that's where
you start because and look governments
over the last 40 years state local and
federal have gotten rid of
public notice ads and those are probably
one of the key things that you need to
build newspapers in fact those
those public notice ads provide
transparency on government everybody can
pick it up and go oh look here's an
estate cell the city council's meeting
friday and salesmen would use those and
lawyers would use them to find clients
and to find people to relate with in the
community and all of that helped build
our communities at the national level we
divide our communities by going you know
right or left but at the local level
everybody wants a paved street everybody
wants their you know the water to work
the lights to work you know the schools
to work hospitals police all of those
things that we have at the you know hey
why is that stoplight not working we can
show up at a city council meeting and
find out but all of those things have
kind of broken down over the years
because of a lack of local and community
newspapers and until we fix that and by
the way that's where most national
stories start
is with community journalism they start
there
and until we invest in community
journalism we're not going to solve our
problems yeah so i mean there's so many
different areas that are factors here
and i'll just name some of them and then
maybe you could tell us whether these
are things that could be solved
individually or whether they're really
all part of the same thing so you've got
okay on the one hand you've got the
internet which has created essentially
this model where at very little cost
you can
essentially rewrite and do reporting by
phone rather than doing real
investigative journalism that has put
pressure on newspapers and other other
media outlets to say well let's let's
divest from the expensive investigative
journalists and instead do this thing so
that's one thing let me mention a couple
others all right well let me address
them one by one oh okay so i don't
forget it in that regard the internet is
a great thing
what newspapers and television and radio
and traditional media did wrong was to
get tied into the perpetual news cycle
and said we can vet facts and people
look people scream to the left and the
right that were that were biased you
know conservatively or biased liberals
no we're biased towards money right
because constriction of the business we
go where the money is yes so you end up
with news that you want rather than news
that you need
and that's the danger of if that was a
management problem and that's because we
have fewer experienced people in this
business anymore who can fend off the
the the need to go first oh they're
showing up live we have to do is take a
look at the steele dossier for example
all right the steele dossier came out
and the very first report said
not vetted this is not vetted
information and yet everyone ran with it
as if it were right that's the problem
so the internet isn't a problem it's a
solution with the right people behind it
no without a doubt so so that's one
piece the technological factors that
have changed things second
um
we look at some other countries there's
a fee everybody pays towards public
broadcasting for example you talk about
what about 100 tax credit if you
subscribe to this or that
we also then have the entire debate
around hey you get a basic cable package
and some number of bucks is going to fox
news or whatever even if you don't want
it to and so people are paying
often
for so-called news that they don't even
actually want so there's that structural
issue that needs to be looked at as well
it seems to me well the problem there is
you need to reinstitute the fairness
doctrine so that you you know what has
happened
in a recent press conference president
biden referred to it as
informational alleys that we go into
alleys where we hear what we want to
hear and not what we need to hear and i
call it in the book informational silos
we're all kind of siloed into our own
existence and we never hear what anybody
else is saying sure well the fairness
doctrine helped increase uh public um
news
i mean it helps spawn the news industry
and so when you reinstitute a fairness
doctrine so you have to listen to at
least listen to the other side on
matters of import then perhaps you can
break down some of those informational
silos from what i've read though the the
the fairness doctrine as it previously
existed would essentially have no teeth
in an age where so much as i mean you
need something different you need
something different because of the
internet right well and that's one of
the things i say in the book is that you
need to have a blue ribbon commission to
look at it you need to institute the
fairness doctrine but you need people in
this industry and lawmakers to assess
how we can
do it
you know so that it makes a difference
the real problem the fairness doctor
never really had
teeth i mean it never did no one was
ever lost a you know a license because
they didn't adhere to the fairness
doctrine it's just that it kind of gave
us all a guardrail that we could all aim
for and so public service uh um
programming public affairs programming
news all was spawned by that i was it
started in 1949 under the truman
administration and people said yeah okay
you know they said
we're going to sell you the airwaves but
for one hour a day or whatever you've
got to do public news and so that was
kind of without any you know real
consequence to it people fell in line
you need that today you need at least
the guard rail and then discuss how you
can make the guardrail solid but yeah it
doesn't it won't work you can't just go
all right reinstate the awareness
doctrine as it existed that won't work
but you need some form of fairness
doctrine to make sure that and make sure
that it does work what about the
socio-cultural shift that has taken
place in terms of attitudes towards news
and this includes two pieces one is
lack of media literacy where people
can't even tell whether they're watching
news or opinion so that's one side
people not really understanding what it
is that they're watching the other side
is this sort of contempt and we could
i'm curious to hear from you how
responsible trump was for this or others
about
if it's adversarial and you don't like
it it's fake or they're lying or they're
biased or or whatever to what degree
is that change and the attitude towards
what news is a problem here well taking
your last one first trump was a symptom
not a cause
trump is a con man who used existing
differences in division and further
exploited them
as he told you know i can't remember who
he told me he said look i i tell people
that you're the fake news so they don't
believe you right well you know don't
that's old that's really an old tactic
you know embodied in the statement don't
shoot the messenger you know we're just
giving it to you pal you don't like it
too bad go clean it up it's not upon us
to to say now we've lost i think to your
first part
what we've lost
over the years is there's a lack of
institutional knowledge and because of
that lack of institutional knowledge
caused by the constriction in our
business and that constriction in our
business was caused by the fact that
when i first got in this business there
were maybe two dozen companies that ran
80 percent of what you see reader here
today there's five that commandeer about
90 of what you see reader here right and
that's because
we removed the restrictions on ownership
and so what happened was as larger and
larger companies began to buy each other
up and as they did bottom line counted
more there were fewer reporters like if
you owned a media conglomerate that used
to be comprised of four different or
five different or a hundred different
newspapers who all had reporters in
washington dc
for their specific newspaper you would
go well i can save money by just having
one reporter there right got rid of a
lot of jobs and experience and it became
more popular when i first got in this
business you had to have three to five
years experience working as a beat
reporter somewhere in a small market so
you understood what it was to be a
reporter right and today they hire you
straight out of school and will hire you
and put you in the white house with no
experience at all and therefore we lose
our credibility because what you end up
with are reporters without experience
who are more you know they're more
susceptible to the access journalism oh
i won't be able to get on air force one
oh i won't be allowed into this room oh
i won't be able to talk to these people
if i do this so that's led to what is a
disgustingly low level of real reporting
in the united states and it's only going
to get worse if we don't fix it you know
it was in 1958 that edward r murrow
appearing before the radio television
news directors association warned us
that if we don't clean up our act we are
destined to fall for nothing but slogans
and propaganda in the future and by god
yeah
we he nailed it
so what's the lowest hanging fruit
because you've got the media literacy
piece you've got the media consolidation
and lack of enforcement of antitrust
peace you've got regulatory fcc net
neutrality fairness doctrine aspect of
this you there there's all these
different things what's the lowest
hanging fruit that would have the
greatest impact most quickly community
newspapers invest in them and give tax
breaks for them and encourage them
and uh that's where you start because
that's where you build reporters
some of the best reporters look why did
walter cronkite have so much gravitas in
1965 i think it was when he went to
vietnam and he he developed he put
together a documentary
which was all fact based and then at the
end of it he offered an opinion it's not
unusual for reporters to offer opinions
he offered one he said it's obvious to
this reporter that we're not going to
win we've got to negotiate our way out
of it and lbj said [ __ ] i've lost middle
america i've lost you know
cronkite i'm doomed i gotta you know i
won't run for re-election why did people
why did people respect that opinion
well because walter cronkite had the
gravitas to
to be able to say it he had covered
world war ii he was a radio beat
reporter he had experience upon
experience upon experience what anchor
today on any news show
has that what what what tell what
newspaper writer today has the gravitas
of an h.l menkin we don't have that
because we have lost
institutional knowledge when you
when it costs too much to have a
reporter around they find other ways to
make money because guess what by the
time you're in your mid 30s or 40s and
you've got a family you can't exist on
what they're going to pay you in this
business as a reporter so if i
understand the community newspaper
community media outlet piece
it's good because number one it creates
more diversity of opinion it's good
because number two it trains reporters
to be ready to go to the national level
number three it's good because
financially it's it's dividing money up
amongst more institutions like there's a
bunch of different ways in which that is
a positive thing right i agree and yeah
yeah i agree because i wrote it but
[Laughter]
but
the and then there are other things you
know like the reinstitution of the
prayer i think you need a national
shield law to protect reporters so they
don't go to jail when they have
confidential sources as a reporter who
was jailed four times i can tell you
it's not fun
um and then the most controversial thing
is and the thing that's that hurts and
bites the most for business is you know
using antitrust legislation to bust up
the big monopolies right but it has to
be done in some respects somehow and
that's why you need a blue ribbon
commission to decide how to do it you
have to have more reporters
on the planet
there are twice the number of people on
this planet today is on the day that i
was born and probably about half the
number of reporters
that's a problem right and it's
illustrated best by a place i used to
work laredo texas
when i worked there in the 1980s there
were a hundred thousand people there
were three television stations that
broadcast in english one that broadcast
or two the broadcast
in um spanish there were two daily
newspapers in english and two in spanish
there were probably four or five radio
stations that broadcast news now that
was
35 years
almost 38 years ago and 100 000 people
today there are 300 000 people and
there's one television station
and one newspaper right right that's it
there's your problem in a nutshell
hey um
we had i'm going to give you two
examples to kind of frame this next
question and you know you tell me what
you think under trump there was this
famous incident where
he flipped out on cnn's jim acosta and
then had his press credential pulled um
after jim acosta insisted on asking a
question and didn't immediately turn
turn the mic over when they tried to
take it from him last week joe biden or
maybe it was this week who knows uh
referred to fox reporter peter ducey as
a son of a [ __ ] and he he may have been
uh
knowingly on the mic or maybe not or
whatever
what those incidents are they equally
concerning in your mind
neither both one the other what do they
mean about the relationship between
federal government and the media first
of all jim acosta is a first amendment
warrior and i love it
and secondly
there were two people that had their
press passes pulled during the trump
administration
jim was the first i was the second and i
had to battle the sob i'll use the word
son of a [ __ ] i had to battle trump
that sob
three times and i beat him three times
in court to keep my press pass right and
jim fought him to keep his press pass
that is what concerns me
i had to stand up in a in a court
a federal court
with my attorney ted butross who was
also a great first amendment warrior and
represented both me and jim yep and and
it was it was
ted who stood up and said you know
the administration said they had to ban
my press pass because if they didn't
come down on me and people like me that
they were afraid that reporters would
run through the halls mooning people
uh
honest to god they that that was what
they said
and imagine having to defend that
taking your time out as a reporter i had
to sit in court for that
me being called an sob by a president i
don't care
peter still gets in and i know peter and
uh i have nothing against any question
that anyone wants to ask in that
briefing room there's no such thing as
bad questions only bad answers
god bless you for asking anything what
may not be the question i'd ask i may
think well that's kind of shallow but
it's it's always the answers that that
are more concerning for us you know
there's the old story told of uh during
betty ford's days when there was a group
of reporters including one fresh off the
choo choo who saw her in a gaggle and
the young reporter said hey did your
kids did your kids ever smoke pot and
everybody thought well that's the
stupidest question in the world right up
until the time where betty ford said yes
right and he was brilliant right
you
you may think a question is stupid and
reflect upon and go well that's a stupid
question but it's not the questions that
matter it's the answers
so i don't care if the the president
wants to call me a dumb sob or anybody
else in this way he gave him access and
and peter can still ask his questions so
there's a difference there a big
difference between having your press
pass yanked
having to go to court to defend it
having a president fundamentally
unknowing or uncaring of what the first
amendment means
and what a press is there for and then a
pro and a president who says hey he's a
dumb sob i mean i've heard presidents
say that pretty much about
every reporter in the white house so
that's not they're not equal they're not
equitable they're not there's no way
they're on the same level and if you
think differently i i invite you to sit
in court with me or jim if you fight to
keep our damn press passes and keep
doing our job yeah yeah the distinct the
exact distinction i made uh after it
happened the new book is free the press
the death of american journalism and how
to revive it the book's author is brian
karam brian really appreciate your time
today
sure any time